here we are at the 2012 u.s. Chess
Championships in st. Louis with just one
round to go I'm Jennifer Sajadi and this
is my klein and we've had a couple of
really exciting rounds as we've reached
the conclusion gotta camp ski played a
fantastic game against grandmaster
yasser sarah juan in which he used a lot
of preparation that he had prepared for
his candidate's match against Apollo it
was a Carol con and he played the
sacrificial move G for Yasser went into
the tent quite quickly and ended up
playing a move that was very fatal we
should take c5 the sacrifices began to
uncork that's right gen con' ski
recalled his match in Kazan and
remembered Bishop takes h6 followed by
rook to d7 the point is that after
Knight takes D 7 Queen to d2 King H 7
and the retreat Knight to g4 cannot be
parried Kamsky had to spend very little
time on his clock in fact gaining time
with the increment and Sarah was reduced
to only one minute left for the
remainder of the game
and by the way God have played
incredibly incredibly fast so I was
really thrown off you know like I did it
I didn't have any rhythm going for me
there was no rhythm it was like I was
taking 5 minutes he played simply ok
that was interesting I play you know I
take 14 minutes he play instantly an
absolutely sparkling game meanwhile
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura had his
hands full with Alexander Lenderman the
game was a marathon over a hundred and
twenty Meuse Nakamura was not able to
break through Linderman a tough fight 85
ohh
then we had the matchup everyone has
been waiting for all tournament
gata Kamsky plain white half a point
ahead of his main rival Grandmaster
Hikaru Nakamura it was a night off with
six a four and God I got absolutely
nothing out of the opening in fact many
grandmasters thought that Nakamura I had
a big edge
now when Nakamura came down to the
commentary room afterwards he said that
the edge was probably mostly optical but
one thing's for sure it put a lot of
pressure on Kamsky and he got into deep
time pressure and after Cara's victory
he briskly went down two flights of
stairs to the commentary room and was
greeted with one of the largest rounds
of applause of the entire tournament he
then Satan answer questions about his
game and his upcoming match tomorrow
yeah well once again maybe shoe
completely took me by surprise there's
it's like being got into play 95 and I
think after 95 rooks see to write the
computer said people told us my shoes
like really horrible move on calm skis
40th and final move before time control
of about a minute left on his clock he
played the move king h4 Nakamura later
called this move unrecoverable Nakamura
played rook a seven painting one night
then played rook takes d5 getting rid of
the other well-placed night Chomsky just
sat there and sat there with his extra
30 minutes and could not find a way to
stop the advance of the eight horn
Nakamura just played a5 a4 a3 a2 a1 and
consecutive moves and there was nothing
calms he could do over in the US Women's
Championship we have two players leading
the cross gable Irina crush and Ana's a
Tom's game on of the times k had her
hands full with rusev Angola Gianni's
reverse Benko but recent on seemed to
lose a thread reared queens 40 and her
knight on h4 proved misplaced honor the
tumski found herself after time control
up to pond and won the rook game easily
yes an arguably irena crush had even
more troubles than on as a Tomsky arena
was white against the lowest seed Elena
Katz
Elena's bishops had proved strong and if
she'd only found 19 fish of a fork
instead of Bishop c4 it was unclear
where Irina's rook would go if it
traveled forward the other Bishop would
trap it and if it travelled sideways the
past d pawn of elena would simply
marched down the chessboard
unfortunately for Elena she didn't find
it and later on a bigger blunder was
waiting exactly she played King to e7
which allowed b5 followed by knight c6
check winning the exchange yeah I think
in my first couple of games I wasn't
really sure what I was doing but then
now like III think my game proved much
more I wish I could just start all over
this left irenan Anna tied for first
going into the last round of the US
Women's Jes Championship so it's all
gonna come down to that final day if
they both win there will be a playoff on
Sunday meanwhile over in the US
Championship we have Hikaru Nakamura a
half a point ahead of the field and he
gets to play white against yasser sarah
Wan where as gata Kamsky is black
against grandmaster Robert has so gonna
be a thrilling last game in fact we
might see two champions crowned tomorrow
so you don't want to miss it it's 1:00
p.m. local time here in st. Louis and 2
p.m. Eastern at us chess champs calm